did you found badier
vodka I did not found beler vodka but I
helped find badier vodka in fact we had
a wonderful experience back in 1993
Chris uh I was uh 24 years old I had
recently joined our family business
after working for a startup company in
the bicycle business for a couple years
we are my grandmother who was the advice
columnist Dear Abby introduced my father
Eddie Phillips and me H to a man named
Tad dorda who was a pole a Polish uh
gentleman who had a proposition uh
relative to the Vodka business so we
thought we could sell our Philips
peppermint schnaps which we made in
Minnesota uh to the Polish market and we
went on a trip to Poland in 1993 my
father Steve Gil our business partner
Tad dorta uh we thought we could sell
some schnaps uh what it turned into is
the Discovery essentially uh of what we
thought was the most beautiful packaging
we'd ever seen in the world and the most
disruptive idea that the biggest
category in spirits had ever seen and
that was what turned into both badier
and chopan bodka and it was that trip
that changed our strategy we negotiated
with the Polish government to obtain the
distribution rights some years later
purchased the intellectual property and
the distilleries and created the world's
first luxury vodka brand and by the way
took on two big Brands absolute and
Stolichnaya that is a little bit of a
metaphor for what I'm doing right now
what was disruptive about
what was disruptive Chris first and
foremost in in a lot of Industries
especially developed Industries you'll
have a couple of really big Brands uh
that essentially command most of the
market and they spend all their time
kind of fighting each other to the
bottom on price attacking each other by
the way the analogy of course is
Democrats and Republicans here in the
United States and what was disruptive is
that we went into a category in which
the most expensive vodka at that time
was about $15 a bottle and we came in at
$25 a bottle we came in with a cork
finish we came in with a very different
proposition predicated on authenticity
but here is the Special Sauce we
recognized that this is in the analog
era by the way Chris you know well
before social media and and the internet
and the like and people but people were
aspirational you know people want to
always live better do better be more
happy have more stuff and what we
recognized is you know people couldn't
buy the same house as the BG celebrities
of the day or have the same car or watch
or dresses but they could buy the same
bottle of vodka for $25 that the most
famous person in the world was drinking
with his or her friends and there was
the disruptive nature of this whole
thing the luxury vodka category was
created it endured for over a decade now
been replaced by tequila of course but
it was the brand badier that really
redefined luxury vodka marketing and
recognized that it's a fashion industry
just like so many others what is the
competitive relationship or what was it
between badier and grey goose because if
I was to show my mom two bottles of
vodka she might even think that it was
two different versions perhaps from the
same company this is one type this is
another my background is in Nightlife so
I ran nightclubs for a decade and a half
a million a million entries across my my
career so I'm intimately familiar with
vodka with Spirits with working bars and
clubs uh but talk to me about that that
competitive landscape you guys come
first you've got this sort of frosted
finish on the bottle it's very
distinctive what where does Greg Goose
did Greg Goose see that and then try and
copy what's what's the story so Chris
you're you're get here's another untold
story what most people don't know is
that when we launched badier vodka we
also launched another PR brand called
rul r o h o l which means motor oil in
German it came in a little black drum
like looked like an oil barrel and we
introduced that to take on Jagermeister
we thought Jagermeister could use a
disruptive brand and at the same time we
introduced rul in the very beginning
Chris we got a lot more interest and
excitement and orders for Ru than we did
for badier and we were really excited
about it well cydney Frank who was the
now deceased owner of the jgermeister I
don't think he was very pleased seeing
his U baby being taken on so he thought
he would go after us as as The Story
Goes
and came out with a vodka that looked
exactly the same as badier so we sued
and we won but here's the lesson learned
we were able to have our graphic design
team redesign The Grey Goose bottle and
let me tell you the lesson is never ask
a graphic design agency to redesign
something to make it look worse because
it doesn't happen they made it look
better and we essentially settled uh
they redesigned Grey Goose it looked
better than ever uh but I'll tell you I
give Sydney Frank credit because what he
recognized Chris is we thought the
badier Vodka category we thought luxury
vodka might be a nice Market you know
not a huge one so we marketed it with a
very very small aperture and Sydney
Frank he came out with a huge aperture
advertising USA Today big displays on
the floor of big retailers and he did a
better job of
recognizing uh the size of the market
and we didn't so Grey Goose outperformed
badier eventually we sold the brand to
lbmh did very well of course but syu
Frank did even better when he sold his
brand to bardi and like anything else in
life you know you win some you lose some
you learn lessons and next time you do
better this feels like a Ferrari
Lamborghini battle between between two
sort of Premium Brands yeah you could
say you could say so you could say so
you could say so and a great story and
and the the other untold story about
badier is uh the fact that Jay-Z had a
lot to do with its early success it
didn't do that well in the beginning and
I was getting ready one morning in
probably 1996 1997 and I have MTV on and
lo and behold Chris I see a music video
Jay-Z video where he's pouring bellier
all over the place he opens a a
refrigerator it's filled with badier
vodka I call my dad it's the analog era
I'm like Dad turn on MTV he didn't know
what channel it was so we waited till we
got to the office that day and the whole
company sat around the TV waiting for
MTV to replay the video and when we saw
it we knew the brand was changed forever
and loone behold Chris we got orders
that maybe tripled within a couple weeks
from all around the country and Jay-Z
and my dad ended up having dinner uh
probably a year later Jay-Z introduced
his own vodka called Armadale which I
don't think anybody remembers because he
saw the opportunity to do for his own
brand what he did for ours and uh that's
the story of badier people don't really
know it talk to me about the principles
that you carried over from that into the
ice cream company
yeah so the same notion of disruption
what we like is to look at a category
that has two big brands that are not
particularly special that dominate the
category and have for a long time and
when we looked at ice cream you had Ben
and& Jerry's and hogendas owned by big
multinational you know food companies
essentially doing the same thing that
stoi and absolute War not a lot of
innovation a lot of Confrontation a lot
of focus on price versus you know value
or uh or um or quality or innovation and
we recognize there's a grand opportunity
um the founder of tente was a young guy
named Josh Haw Schuler who became our
partner and the Beautiful part of that
story is because he had so little he had
a gelato shop that was not doing well in
Dallas Texas got an order to package the
gelato in containers for the local
grocery store but he could not afford to
actually print like a nice ice cream
pint that you see all over the world so
he had to go to a a basically a surplus
store and he found on closeout a bunch
of clear plastic jars that he could just
put a label on it was the only way he
could do it and that is the beauty of
tanti gelato it was transparent it was
in a redefining package just like badier
and we did the same thing we priced it
just a little bit higher more luxurious
and we elevated a category that was
still an affordable luxury so you could
drink you could drink the finest vodka
in the world for $25 and you could enjoy
the finest gelato made on Earth for only
$5 a pint and it's the same notion
affordable luxury branded very very well
and we sold it to Unilever seven years
later what did you learn from the lvmh
and Unilever negotiations I've had a
number of friends that have exited
companies to one of them to to Unilever
and a bunch of others to equally large
uh negotiating competent companies what
were the lessons that you took that you
took away from
that I will tell you without diving too
deeply into the details let me just tell
you that I think unver is a more
principled
corporation that I think stands more by
their word and a company of Great
Character that does a lot of good for
the world uh I think I could not say
quite as kind of things about lbmh and
that transaction and I will just leave
it at that okay I understand and I think
you know what I mean there's a really
interesting principle from uh Chris
voss's never split the difference well
he talks about in in a negotiation you
can get yourself to the stage where you
get absolutely everything that you want
but if it's so aggressive that the other
party feels like they've been bent over
calls there is a it's almost it's not
quite a pic Victory but there is a loss
in the victory to some degree because
you
know unless you don't care about the way
that you leave the world after you leave
it you have sort of
fundamentally it's it's become a a zero
some game or even less than a zero some
game so true I'm glad you say that in
fact I had a great-grandfather Chris Jay
Phillips who immigrated from what was
then Bell well then the Russian Empire
Minsk came to the us as just a little
boy at age eight years old started
selling uh newspapers on a street corner
outside of Milwaukee Wisconsin
eventually moved to Minnesota and
entered the spirits business right after
prohibition uh and became one of the
biggest Distributors of spirits in the
country and of course the company that
ultimately introduced belv vodka he told
me three things when I was a young man
and he said Dean money is like manure if
you stack it up it stinks and if you
spread it out it fertilizes he said
business is a means to an end and the
end is not aggregating as much wealth as
humanly possible the joy of business is
to share it with as many people as
possible in the communities that make
the business successful and he also said
Dean you always have to leave a little
something on the table for the next guy
which was his way of saying in a
negotiation you know what it's actually
the mench it's actually the strong
person that leaves a little bit more uh
even when you're in a position of
strength which by the way I've seen the
same Dynamic play out in Congress a
number of times but those are the his
lessons and the same is true I think in
business negotiations you know it's not
just about the capital it's not just
about the money it's about how people
are treated afterwards your employees
how the communities in which you've done
business are treated I I wish more
entrepreneurs would be mindful uh of how
their exits sometimes impact families
and communities in ways that they didn't
anticipate and I wish more deals were
structured uh to guarantee a little bit
more left over for a lot of people who
work really hard to create success and
are not really thought about at the end
and we've done a I think a very nice job
in our businesses to make sure that
those who make it possible share and I
that's kind of part of my notion in
Congress and uh about government now too
you know how do we ensure that everybody
has a foundation from which they can
pursue their dreams and right now I
don't think the United States in
particular is doing a good job and I
think too many companies uh reward the
very top of their management team and do
not express the same consideration and
empathy towards those on the bottom end
of their socioecon economic scale okay
so you pivoted from the mck andm of
business into the Mucky and more Meer
ridden world of politics which one's
more
Cutthroat oh there's no Congress is more
Cutthroat because it's because the rules
and engagement are amorphous uh
friendships are not legitimate they're
transactable and it is a strangely talk
about zero sum game uh this Spirit of
collaboration of of a culture of debate
deliberation of learning of Discovery
you know the basics of doing better in
one's life whether it's business or any
kind of pursuit are almost totally
absent it is almost in exclusively Chris
a culture of self-preservation people
who wish to Simply Be A Part part of the
club and to stay a part of the club and
do what it takes to remain a member of
the club and as the only one you know
there are 535 members of the United
States Senate and House I'm the only one
that doesn't take any pack money with is
political action committee money which
is money from special interest groups
corporate or Union I don't take any
money from them I don't take any
lobbyist money I don't give money to
fellow members of the US Congress or
accept theirs and I don't have what they
called a leadership pack which is a
basic a slush fund that American
politicians can use at their own
disposal which makes me the only one out
of 535 people that doesn't play that
game uh I was the vice chair of the
problem solvers caucus intending to get
together with my Republican friends and
talk build trust get to know each other
because leaders on both sides of the
aisle don't do that I sered on the
modernization committee in the last
Congress trying to fix the social
organizational and physical design flaws
of Congress and then last Congress I was
elected to a leadership position by my
peers hoping that I could really affect
change but as long as the culture
attracts people who are almost
exclusively government service folks
that don't have a lot of private sector
experience and as long as the culture
rewards silence and staying in line uh
and obediency it's going to be the same
disaster for the United States and
frankly I think for the world as long as
we populate it with people that are
beholden that system that's one reason
I'm running for president to expose the
truth uh provide a little bit of common
sense and competency to a place and at a
time we really need
it it's becoming more and more like
House of Cards uh every sentence that
you say it's weird right because you
know as a muggle outside of the system
we
see the rumors and the accusations and
and and the the the gossip and stuff
that creeps out and then we see the
dramatization with you know shows like
House of Cards westwing or whatever
and and V which AMU inui who originally
did uh the thick of it which is where
that came from the British equivalent
which is Phenom it's my favorite comedy
of all time
um both of those actually play off the
back of it's there's some gamesmanship
and there's some corruption but the the
main joke behind both vep and the thick
of it is ineptitude it's that the people
who are in Char it's it's idiots all the
way up the people who are in charge are
not no smarter than you average person
watching this but perhaps actually a
little bit more stupid and an awful lot
more sheltered what is the average
leader as smart as the average Watcher
in your opinion oh Chris you're going to
get me in trouble um Let me let me tell
you the oldest joke in Congress and I
felt it uh the first day I'm elected I'm
sitting on the house floor I'm looking
up at this massive Eagle in the ceiling
of the United States House of
Representatives in the literally the
Temple of democracy y as recognized by
the whole world and it's the evening and
it's dark and with all my new colleagues
and I look around and I think to myself
Chris how did I get here how in the
world did I get here and then about a
week later I'm sitting in the same room
whole place is filled with Democrats and
Republicans from all over the country
and I'm looking around and I think how
did they get here
ah so to your point that's an old joke
in Washington and look at I don't
there's some wonderful smart uh
remarkable people in Washington uh both
Democrats and Republicans are they the
majority no absolutely not uh and I
think part of the problem is we are now
in a an era not just in the United
States but where public service and po
politics are
attracting the people who are there for
reasons that are much more personal than
they are out of principle and and
because of the culture of condemnation
and anger tainment and uh constant
fundraising it doesn't attract the kind
of people of Competency of life
experience of professional experience
that should be populating at least to
some degree uh our institutions of uh of
government so the answer is I think
that's a big part of the problem and one
of my mandates and personal missions is
to reintroduce the notion of Public
Service uh to a younger generation that
have great ideas that right now don't
even consider it and I think that's a
big part of the problem if we only hand
the keys to people who have their own
personal agenda uh or their uh interest
is in tenure and preservation of power
uh we're going to be poorly served as we
have been in recent years and that's
something we got to change fast I read
something that said it's recommended
when people join Congress that they
spend 25 hours a week on fundraising
calls and if you are what you do we're
primarily sending fundraisers to DC and
if you include flights and travel it's
perfectly likely that you'll basically
have no time to actually get anything
done so how much do you do that's work
and how much do you do that's fluff like
how much gamesmanship is occurring and
how much actual graft gets done well
Chris I'm getting in good trouble by
saying the quiet part out loud and
here's the quiet part members of
Congress are spending
10,000 hours per week raising money you
just you just said the number 25 hours
times over 500 people do the math 10,000
hours per week collectively in fact I
wrote a bill uh that is pending that
would preclude fundraising in Washington
from breakfast to dinner time because
all my colleagues are constantly raising
money I told you earlier I'm one of 535
that does it differently which means
it's hard for me to find a friend to
have dinner with on a Wednesday night
because they're all at fundraisers and
even during the day at committee
hearings and educational opportunities
and constituent visits people are not
around because they're across the street
either Dialing for Dollars or raising
money from packs or lobbyists or at a
law firm or something it's sickening but
it's legalized corruption and here's the
biggest issue though prit if I could
just say the biggest issue is this yes
the money corrupts because if you are
getting paid by somebody even if it's
going into your campaign Coffer if
you're getting money from somebody
they're generally doing it because they
want something in return they want
influence they want access they want you
to vote a certain way of course we're
not stupid the biggest issue is this
though when you only congregate with the
wealthy and well-connected you if you
don't mean to but the system requires
that you do all you're hearing about is
their problems which tend to be issues
that are the last things on the mind of
struggling people all around the world
so we have a system right now that
forces everyone to spend their time with
the wealthy and well-connected Democrats
and Republicans and that's why we have
trumpism in America because 150 million
Americans are saying you know what my
member of Congress never listens to me
they never show up in my neighborhood
they've never called me to ask me for
anything I don't even know how to reach
them I'm unheard my issues don't matter
I can barely afford my life and all you
all are sitting in Washington having
stake dinners getting your money and
acting like morons that's what people
think and that's why I'm trying to do
this differently Chris it's the fact
that our system is forcing people to
behave in a way that is destructive to
democracy and all we have to do is
change the reward system and re Empower
voters and disempower the wealthy and
well-connected in Washington it's not
rock science and I know how to do it
it's why the rich men north of Richmond
song I think caught fire exactly exactly
he was speaking for tens of millions of
frustrated people and I'm hearing it
every day I get it you know I I don't
know if you know my story you know but
Chris I was I lost my dad in Vietnam
when I was just six months old he had no
money uh which is why he earned an ROTC
scholarship to get his education and
then went to Vietnam and lost his life I
was 6 months old my mom was 24 and
widowed we lived with my
great-grandparents in St Paul Minnesota
until I was 3 years old uh and then I
was adopted I got really lucky I got
adopted into an amazing family with all
kinds of blessings and Privileges and
love you know very few kids who lost
their dads in Vietnam got lucky like I
did very few kids who lost their mom's
or dad in Afghanistan or Iraq got lucky
like I did and I'm realizing right now
that we have to recognize our Good
Fortune every one of us who has
succeeded had somebody that believed in
us somebody that gave us a hand somebody
that recognize something in us this
notion that only doing it alone is the
American dream is nonsensical and I
think what we're seeing right now is a
uh real erosion of a belief that things
are possible in America and around the
world if people work hard because the
system is stacked to support the wealthy
and the well-connected I know it having
lived on both sides of it it's like I've
got it in my head that it's kind of like
a a status driven Ponzi
scheme so it constantly needs more
favors to be bestowed from the bottom to
pay the favors at the top and no one
really except for the fact that in a
Ponzi scheme the people at the bottom
all of the people except for the people
at the top know are unaware of the fact
that it's going on whereas this it's a
cartel it's a cartel of people
permanently cycling through a variety of
things and everyone is it seems what
you're saying is true everybody is on
board with just don't stop the music
from playing we just need to keep the
status quo going that's and that's what
happens in a duopoly in a duopoly both
participants wish to protect the status
quo because they know how to manage it
they're accustomed to it they know the
game and they don't want competition and
whether it's Coke and Pepsi with Red
Bull whether it was Ben and Jerry's with
tente whether it was absolute and
stolich sha with badier when you disrupt
a category they come at you hard man and
they're coming at me hard they don't
want the quiet part set out loud they
don't want the truth to be told and they
don't want the fact that this is corrupt
to be exposed even if it's legal because
they're trying to protect it and I have
faith I have faith that if you tell the
truth and let people know what's really
going on that they'll take notice and
what you just said is absolutely true I
don't want to impune all the people
because the fact is the system requires
this Behavior for you to stay alive you
know I I I made the decision to torpedo
my career in the United States Congress
after three terms I Knew by making this
decision that I could probably never
come back and that's unique because
there are very few who are willing to
give up their careers to do the right
thing and that's what makes me a little
what did I do well I I resigned my house
leadership position and I decided I'm
going to run for president of the United
States against a sitting incumbent
president which is rarely
done but this is not a normal time this
is not a normal election the opponent is
not a normal human being and our current
likely nominee is an unelectable human
being but I tell you the party does not
like that I'm getting out of line that
I'm not waiting my turn that I am not
abiding by those unspoken rules of what
you do or don't do with an incumbent
president and I recognized if I did this
I would be spending every ounce of
political Capital that I had earned and
I worked hard to earn it over my three
terms but I recognized that if I didn't
do this now I wouldn't be meeting the
moment and it's not about 2028 or 2032
or about a lifetime aspiration to become
president it's about doing this right
now because it is existential and Donald
Trump in my estimation is an existential
threat to the United States of America
and to the rest of the world period did
people not say that before his last term
sure they did in fact a lot of my
colleagues my Republican colleagues said
the same thing quietly and then they'd
get in front of the cameras at night
Chris and say something totally
different and lo and behold little did I
know that that disease was contagious
because suddenly on my side of the aisle
Democrats were having the same
conversations about Joe Biden he's not
electable bomic is ridiculous his
approval numbers are horrifyingly low
he's not going to win in the
Battleground States Vice President
Harris is even in worse shape as it
relates to her approval numbers but then
they in front of the cameras and it's a
totally different story and we wonder
why Americans have lost faith in their
government because they know and when
260 or so Democrats serve in the US
House and Senate and we see data that
says over 50% of Democrats want a
different nominee 83% of Democrats under
30 want a different nominee but only one
person in the whole Congress out of 260
is willing to say it out loud publicly
that's me you can imagine there's
something wrong there's something really
really wrong what do you think happens
in 12 months time if there's no change
from here who who do you think becomes
president if nothing else changes well I
think I will ultimately become the
Democratic nominee it's going to take
time uh many people right now don't see
that path I certainly do I think come
May of June yeah June of next year we'll
see head-to-head polls that will show me
ahead of Donald Trump I'm a former
businessman than the board chair of a
health system a regent at University
been the chair of the board of a
charitable uh philanthropy served three
terms in the house a former Democratic
leader I'm the ranking member of the
Middle East subcommittee on Foreign
Affairs and the vice ranking member of
the small business committee I've got a
lot of experience I think I will be able
to put together to the Coalition you
need to win in America by inviting
Donald Trump supporters who deserve and
are worthy of invitation not
condemnation I'll be ahead of Donald
Trump Joe Biden is almost certainly
certainly going to be behind him even
further and then Democrats will have a
choice at the convention do we elevate a
candidate who is likely to win or do we
literally choose the candidate that that
the data is saying is likely to lose
that's a pretty clear choice and I think
it's one that Democrats will do well in
uh because I think they'll choose me and
by the way Chris if some other candidate
appears enters the primary and has
approvals or polls that are even better
as it relates to Donald Trump then I
should get behind that person that's the
whole point of democracy is let people
decide who is best positioned to win but
in the United States uh we are not a
culture that is supposed to endorse and
tolerate coronations but that's
exactly exactly what this country is
doing right now despite the fact that it
literally secured its independence from
that very system of
Coronation yeah it's this sort of every
fouryear cycle of uh
hereditarian where whoever is in gets
passed on again and that goes down what
so in your estimation if it's a Biden
Trump head-to-head come 2024 what's the
outcome oh almost if I had to put all my
money if you had this if you said Dean
you had to take every dollar and assets
you have and put it on just one or the
other based on what I think is going to
happen sadly I'd have to put it all on
Trump every single bit of data every
single bit Chris his approval number
the intuition when you speak with voters
in our country the intuition that Joe
Biden is not only is he not better off
than he was four years ago he is so much
worse off uh the the the polling data in
the Battleground states in the National
numbers you know all of it points to the
same thing and by the way the worst of
it is today there was a poll that was
just released today that shows that
voters in the United States between 18
and 29 years old favor Donald Trump by
six points that is a
cataclysmic change for Democrats and
that is why my proposition is we got to
wake up before we sleep off into a
unmitigated disaster so that's the way
things are going but that's why I'm
running is because we need an
alternative need a change to a new
generation I'd be the first Gen X
president in American history you know
Joe Biden was born before the Advent of
Television before the Advent of
Television how in the heck can he Donald
Trump address the issues of AI for
goodness sakes everybody you know what
you what have you learned observing RFK
Jr's trajectory over the last few months
I have to say generally speaking I
admire how he's conducted himself he's
appealing to people using
non-traditional platforms which by the
way you can imagine the minute I
declared my candidacy uh and was no
longer part of the establishment uh I
get stonewalled from a lot of the core
you know the the the major media
platforms MSNBC and some of the others I
think RFK Jr suffered the same thing he
saw the writing on the wall so he
started going to where people are which
is exactly what I'm doing I'm doing that
with you right now for example uh I
think his videos the way he expresses
himself the way he presents information
I'd say 80% of what he says sounds
pretty darn reasonable to me now there
are a couple things 20% of what he says
is pretty damn unreasonable to me I have
to say uh we see science a little bit
differently we see uh health and
Medicine a little bit differently and we
certainly see vaccinations a little bit
differently but I do believe he should
be heard I believe there's a place and
and space for people like RFK and Maran
Williamson and others to be heard I just
wish they were running in the Democratic
primary so that we could all make our
cases within this construct if you will
that allows Democrats to choose the
person best position to win uh because
when you run as a third party candidate
Chris in the US it it has the tendency
to draw votes from the person you
actually are trying to you would rather
see win and since we don't have rank
Choice voting yet in the United States
that can be very dangerous but I think I
think RFK is appealing to a lot of
people for good reason people are sick
and tired of the nonsense uh they're
sick and tired of the corruption they
want someone to tell the truth and of
course he's got an extraordinary
political name but I also have to point
out the other obvious here too Chris you
know you've got Joe Biden has been doing
this for 50 years you've got before that
you had the clintons Hillary and Bill
Clinton then you had the bushes now
you've got the Trump family right you
know and and the Kennedy family is back
you know I I I think it's time for a
little bit something new uh not a
political Dynasty per se not a
coronation but it's time for America I
think to move to a new chapter and
that's why I wish there were more
candidates who are coming coming from
the outside that are not part of that
political industrial complex which I
think is why Donald Trump did so well he
appealed to people who who saw him as a
little bit of a messiah if you will as
an outsider and I have that ability to
kind of build the bridge of both I came
from the outside I'm a business person
and I'm taken on an establishment and a
structure that is that they're defending
almost at all costs from the truth you
know from us telling the truth in that
respect Kennedy and I and some others I
think are going to expose what people
should really know more about and it's
not
pretty just how bated is the current
system inside of Congress how hard is it
to talk across the
aisle well I'm unique uh out of 535
members of Congress and 50 US Governors
I'm ranked number two most bipartisan
I'm a progressive my heart's a
progressive who's number one Susie Lee
my friend Democratic friend from Nevada
I gave her a hard time on the house
floor the other day I said Susie you
totally ruined my whole deal I I was
number one last Congress now I'm number
two but like Avis Car Rentals I'm number
two but I try harder so that's how I I
do it the oldfashioned way Chris man I
you know I break bread with people I
grab a beer I get to know them my
dearest friends in Congress are both
Democrats and Republicans my wife anaise
and I we've befriended wonderful couples
by hosting them at our house for dinner
getting to know each other spending time
with each other's families because you
can't work with people you don't trust
and you can't trust people you don't
know and when you've got in the case of
Nancy Pelosi and Kevin McCarthy instead
of them pushing members of Congress
together when I joined the Congress in
2019 they did just the opposite you know
they put us on separate buses going to
separate events they didn't get us to
tell each other our life stories they
didn't give us much education they
wanted us consumed with fundraising
because they didn't want the power
structure challenged so I had to do it
differently and that's what I've been
doing and as president I should tell you
the most important when I'm president
I'm going to do it fundamentally
differently I'm gonna have a Team of
Rivals in the White House I want
Democrats and Republicans on my cabinet
I want extraordinary the very best and
brightest Americans running the agencies
who are competent managers who've run
multi-billion dollar Enterprises before
who focus on customer service who can
deliver better value at lower costs I'm
going to have a youth cabinet of a a
high school or college student from
every state in the country 50 total
sharing ideas on policy with me in the
white house I'm G to have common ground
dinners in the white house where we have
Democratic and Republican Americans from
all around the country having dinner
with their president in a casual setting
getting to talk to him in this case
sharing what's important you know not
just Black Tie Affairs with celebrities
and heads of state you know it is the
old school notion of people with people
in an era where everything we're doing
Chris is behind screens a lot of it
valuable but it's also destroying the
very fabric of what the world is going
to need much more of as we move forward
which is relationships between the US
and China between fellow Americans you
know between Brits and Americans I mean
if we don't build Relationships by
breaking bread and looking each other in
the eyes uh it doesn't matter what the
future holds in terms of technology or
wealth
it's going to destroy humankind and
that's just the truth it seems from the
outside looking in to the political
sphere and also to the cultural sphere
of looking at the left there is a huge
amount of puritanism a massive Purity
spiral where any dissenting voice is
treated with a unique kind of
skepticism
disain absolutely
how just looking at that from the
outside what what do you wish that the
left stopped doing so much why is that
Purity spiral so rampant and and and how
can you maintain any in-group favoritism
without being totally at the mercy of
ideology well I to answer your question
very directly I I think those on the
furthest left who believe that they
believe in inclusion are actually
practicing the very worst form of
exclusion and that's as it relates to to
debate and conversation you know the
only in business I the same grandfather
I told you about my great-grandfather
used to say if two people in a business
I agree you only need one of them and
his message was surround yourself with
people who have different opinions who
have different life experiences and have
different ideas and when you solicit
them don't just solicit them from the
management class go into the go into the
production Department talk to the sales
reps right this notion of Discovery the
beautiful part of being a human being is
learning you know what a blessing to be
you where you get to listen to
Fascinating People provoke you all the
time what a what a cool thing so why
would we as human beings wish to deny
ourselves of the very opportunity to
learn from another human being doesn't
mean we're going to like they I I don't
disagree but it has become almost the
signature of the left now to not listen
to dissenting opinions to take a
minority opinion and allow that to
tyrannize everybody including the people
that aren't even a part of that party
like is that something that can even be
fixed are you thinking about that yes
that's why I'm running look at Chris I'm
on a I don't want to say a last ditch
effort because I hope this is the
beginning of some fundamental change on
a lot of issues as it relates to my
party and my family if you will and
that's one of my my missions is to
restore those conversations restore the
Public Square restore debate not stifle
it not shame someone for look at if
someone expresses a hateful point of
view that puts another human being at
risk
I think that is a I do draw the line
there and I do think there are some
bigots and some misogynists and some
racists and anti-semites and
islamophobes out
there that will that are terribly
hurtful to other human beings and I I do
I take exception to it and I have
animist towards them but as it relates
to political perspective as it relates
to policy propositions as it relates to
differences of opinion we should be F
democrats should be fostering those
spaces and places not shutting it down
and yes it is salvageable but it takes
leadership President Biden is not
creating that space in place I want
Americans to see I want it modeled by
their president about how you actually
engage different opinions that's why I'm
going to have a cabinet that is going to
be very different and I like to have
some of these meetings televised so that
people can see how different opinions
can be shared without uh condemnation
and separation and segregation to the
just the opposite and that's why I'm
grateful for platforms that are willing
to invite different people with
different ideas to share them if you
don't like it don't listen if you don't
like it don't listen or if you don't
like it take your turn and explain your
perspective but don't shame and Shout
people down into um into um and
dehumanize them in that way unless it's
painful speech that is hurting other
human beings and frankly I think most of
what the left is doing right now the
farle at least is just shutting down all
debate how do you know when the left's
gone too
far look at I I believe first of all I'm
a common sense human being you know more
than anything else before I'm an
American before I'm a Jewish American
before I'm a Democrat before I'm a
father a son a husband you know I'm a
common sense human being that has an
open mind and an open heart and I have a
high threshold for anger when I get
there I get there and I'm Resolute and
I'm principled but I have a pretty good
instinct when something doesn't seem
right when someone seems to be lying
when something doesn't seem to be
reasonable I love new ideas I love it
when people try to convince me to this
very day that the Earth is flat or that
we have UFOs I love those conversations
Chris we should have more of those you
know but when someone says something
that is just
baselessly horrifyingly
dangerous that's a little bit different
and um I can't tell you I've got a meter
or some type of a red light green light
system but I tell you I'm feeling more
and more that there are things that I
want to say that I sometimes can't that
I know a lot of people want to say that
they sometimes can't and that's why one
of my slogans is I'm going to say the
quiet part out loud no matter what it
does no matter the implications no
matter the consequences because I've
actually suffered probably the worst
consequence essentially ended my career
in Congress and have drawn the IR of
probably hundreds of people in
Washington that used to be my very very
good friends and I'm doing so because I
think a truth has to be told that
sometimes will be very much aligned with
those on the left and sometimes we be
very disappointing when they hear the
truth and I would ask my friends on the
right to be open to the same thing there
are going to be some things I say that
you are going to totally agree with and
you're going to hear some things that I
frankly think you need to hear that you
may not at all and so be it I'll hug it
out afterwards as long as you're not
threatening another human being it seems
pretty easily defined when the right
goes too far but you know we've seen
over the last few years a total
inability or inaptitude or just
unpreparedness from people from the left
to call out the extreme parts of that
you know y mostly fiery but peaceful
protest comes to mind uh why do you
think it's so hard to call out groups
like antifa and and other what are
supposedly left aligned groups causing
Havoc Chris I'm I'm struggling with that
right now as as a Jewish American you
can imagine people who I consider to be
protectors Defenders progressives who
were I was the protector of the underdog
I've kind of seen that affection um stop
at our front door and that's hard you
can imagine that's really hard right now
and I'm trying to reconcile that um
there are a lot of communities that have
been disenfranchised that have been
oppressed that have been
mistreated uh in this country and all
around the world and rather than
condemning one another or separating
from one another my proposition is we
should be uniting with each other and I
don't quite understand that I'm
processing that right now um I don't
want people to be colorblind I want
people to look at each other and love
our differences and actually be
attracted to those differences and I
don't quite understand what this disease
is uh there's a disease on the right and
there is a disease on the left and it is
not pervasive but I think it's
contagious and I think it's afflicting
more and more people every day but it's
still a small minority and Chris I would
say that I represent the massive number
of the exhausted majority not just in
the United States but literally around
the world people who just want decency
and respect have a chance to put food on
the table for their families take them
on vacation maybe once a year retire
with dignity uh and have the joy of
living a a life of of Pursuits and
Discovery and love you know it's not
that much and governments have not done
a good job of protecting that
encouraging it investing in it and
enabling it and these on the far right
and the far left I think have to be
disenfranchised and that's my
proposition to Americans right now go
and vote in the primary change this
nonsense break down this duopoly and
let's demonstrate to the world that it
is still possible that's exactly what
I'm trying to do I do like the idea of
the exhausted majority I think that's a
a good way to categorize it would you
define the problems of the extreme right
and the extreme left in different ways
how would you how how do you
conceptualize those what is the problem
of the extreme right and what is the
problem of the extreme left in your
perspective well I'll tell you I think
there's actually more that's similar
than that's different I think at the
core of this believe it or not Chris is
groups of people who who believe in
their hearts that they have been
mistreated and that they've been
disenfranchised on the far right it's
just a very different version of it on
the on the left it's a lot of people who
are representing legitimate gripes about
mistreatment black Americans have been
horribly mistreated by the United States
of America slavery was a repulsive
policy that should have ended far before
it did and it has a long long tale
Native Americans were horribly
mistreated in this country uh Muslim
Americans Jewish Americans right
Hispanic Americans Asian Americans lgbtq
plus Americans everybody who can feel
some degree of animosity
disenfranchisement persecution you know
have been mistreated and they have
rightful gripes about the need and
desire and their right to be included so
if you look at both sides at the they're
very different circumstances I believe
on the left I understand that
disenfranchisement that persecution on
the far right it tends to be more white
Americans who feel that they are being
replaced who feel that somehow their
culture is being changed how they're um
no longer at some point the white
Americans are going to be the majority
they're that they're being persecuted
they're being kept down they're being uh
eliminated and I think that is actually
interestingly enough a very kind of a
similar ethos that actually connects the
far right and the far left it is this
notion of mistreatment and they're angry
I believe like I said I believe my
brothers and sisters on the left I
understand that better but on the right
I think in terms of their hearts and
Minds that is the root of it it's this
notion of being replaced or being second
or being a lower class citizen or
something that scares them when the
other side is saying we've been lower
class citizen forever and we just want a
fair chance but that connects people I
think if we just sat back and
acknowledged you know the human elements
of both of these conditions uh we could
actually have conversations about it and
um instead we do it through television
screens often through anger tainment or
Tik Tok and we're only getting further
and further pushed into the corners
which is what Alvin Toffler warned us
about in Future Shock uh you know 50
years ago I think the problem that
people have when you look toward the
left and
the empathy that is proclaimed to kind
of Drive the we are helping the
underclass we are bringing these people
along is that they don't believe that
it's genuine empathy they it's
performative empathy or it's toxic
compassion so toxic compassion is the
prioritization of short-term emotional
Comfort over everything else so it's
saying saying the good thing whilst
doing something which may be bad or
giving somebody a solution which in the
immediate may make them feel okay but
over the long term could even result in
worse outcomes for them the police
coming from people that live within
gated communities right it's all well
and good saying defund the police when
you've got private security or a locked
compound or you live in a suburb that
doesn't have any crime uh the talk about
single parent households being no worse
for children's outcomes than dual parent
households like it's just it factually
not true and it doesn't inform parents
teachers and uh the
their friends about why the kids are
behaving in this way the body positivity
movement saying that there's no link
between body weight and health outcomes
because they don't want to hurt the
feelings of people that are overweight
even if it causes them to die sooner
literally to die sooner that's toxic
compassion prioritization of short-term
emotional Comfort over everything else
in the long term and I think that that's
the skepticism that a lot of people have
around the left that it is being
so it's been the signature move to say
the thing right to post the Tweet or the
square or the whatever it is and then to
forget about what the actual outcomes
are and to not even bother to scrutinize
these companies to not bother to
scrutinize whether or not BLM are
actually taking the money and putting it
in anywhere that's supposed to be
profitable or useful for the outcomes
that they espoused in the
beginning I I think what you share is um
is is compelling and you know anybody
who's a parent knows that that's the
daily struggle of being a parent
shortterm you know pain for long-term
gain how do you incentivize encourage
without diminishing how do you the
people of means you know how do you
reward your children with enough to
start their lives but not so much that
you literally uh limit their their
aspirations right appear parents from
households that don't have much you know
how do you how do you manage your kids
how do you give them hope and
opportunity when you don't these are the
challenges that I think every Community
every household faces and now it's we're
just talking about a you know entire
cultures and I think you're absolutely
right you know I think we should be
using evidence to Enlighten our
decision-making I think we should be
even if it's tough love I think
democrats should be more focused on
generating and encouraging and investing
in Independence that's why I think we
need healthc care for all housing for
all and educ education for all and then
once you have the foundation then it is
up to you to either succeed or fail but
I think we should be raising the
foundation I think that's what the left
should be doing but I see the tug OFW
you're talking about right now and I
don't think either side has it entirely
right I do think the exhausted majority
which combines elements of conservative
principles with more Progressive
principles both fiscally and socially
that's where most of it is at that's
where most Americans are at but we don't
have a system that allows such leaders
to R
we have a system that by definition by
almost by definition and by intent
pushes candidates the further left and
further right and then puts voters in
the horrifying position of having to
choose between the lesser of two evils
time and time and time again I just want
to have normal conversations acknowledge
the truth you know say things that we do
have a border crisis that defund the
place is foolish you can embed social
workers in police departments which we
should be doing but we should not reduce
law enforcement especially in
communities that needed the most I'm
coming from Minneapolis where George
Floyd was murdered where we
misunderstood that quiet does not mean
peace you know what I mean Chris we must
quiet for peace there's a lot of anger
around the world lot of anger in this
country in America right now a lot of
anger in a lot of communities right now
just because they're quiet does not mean
things are peaceful so yeah we got to
say the quiet part out loud we got to
stop the nonsense we got to speak the
truth we got to have people at the table
of different perspectives and opinions
coming to better conclusions uh we got
to do that fast got to do it fast what
would you say of the structural
pathologies of the left when you're
looking at the uh Democratic institution
the Democrat
institution what is it getting wrong
there's obviously this sort of purity
test cannibalism thing that occurs what
is it from being inside of the machine
what is it that Democrats are getting
wrong
structurally well I think I first of all
I think you know I'm a Democrat because
I believe that Hubert Humphrey was my
idol and he said the moral test of a
government is how it treats those in the
dawn of Life The Dusk of life and in the
shadows of life I think that is the
fundamental role of government to
protect those uh that need defense and
support uh and to look out for those who
are struggling and I do think Democrats
generally come from a position of
fairness pointing out inequities onfair
circumstances and trying to fight for
fairness but I also believe that
Democrats the left if you will are
employing stereotyping just as um
dangerously as as any group I believe um
the lack of willingness to look at um uh
Talent uh to look at possibility uh
versus just looking at categories or
identities I think that's hard uh for
country that Prides itself on being a
multicultural Bastion where meritocracy
should be ultimately the goal whereas
certain communities I think do need a
little extra boost not a hand out but a
hand up I think that's not unreasonable
but I do I look at I know not I not I
think I know that Democrats are being
subject to the very some of the very
disenfranchising dangerous practices
that uh we have long accused the right
uh of of practicing and that means
stereo typing and that means not looking
at people for who they really are rather
just what they represent and I think
that's dangerous and at the end of the
day Chris this all comes back to the
same thing you know if we don't create
space and place for human beings to know
get to know each other we're going to
lose particularly in an era in which we
are so able to self- select not just
with whom we live and eat and pray and
sleep and think but even where we spend
now our our virtual time we can microtar
Target just to be surrounded by people
who see things and think exactly the
same way not only is that a boring life
if you ask me it's a really dangerous
condition that I think needs an antidote
and I think uh people like you and
people like me and I think people who
are watching right now can all play a
little bit of a role in doing something
over the next year that maybe opens up
the opportunity to break bread with
someone who see things differently or
looks differently or prays differently
and there we can actually leave some
change and maybe end this nonsense I
observed this really interesting Dynamic
occur with a lady called Melissa Carnie
so she works out of Washington actually
she is a uh statistician uh demographer
uh looking largely at the outcomes of
single parent households and she just
wrote a book called the two parent
Advantage uh the clue is in the title
this is the difference between single
parent and dual parent household
outcomes I pushed her quite hard in the
episode to try and get out over her uh
statistician skis and think about think
about mechanisms like what is it that's
going on so get it you know a little bit
of bro psychology uh and she was fine to
sort
of give theories but she was very
reticent about about saying you know
this is not my area of expertise so on
and so forth so what I'm saying is that
she wrote a book that was planned to try
and inform people coming from single
parent households people considering
people working through relationships and
marriages and family life and so on and
so for to better understand why the
outcomes that they're looking at and why
the Dynamics and phenomena that they're
looking at are the ones that are
happening and when I asked her to get
out over her skis she said no so she was
very aware of her own restrictions
before her book went live on Twitter uh
just the title of the book was released
no one had seen a galley copy no one had
seen a review copy nothing like that and
she was destroyed mostly by people from
the left for this is conservative
thinking being repurposed this is you
know back to a Christian Nation all this
sort of stuff it's derating people from
underprivileged like workingclass
backgrounds etc etc etc and what I saw
was a lady who when I spoke to her on
the show very touchy feely didn't ask
her about her politics but I would guess
that she's probably Center left and I
saw online the exact dynamic that we've
observed occur publicly with tons of
people that the Democrats and the left
have made life so inhospitable to
anybody who doesn't tow the party line
even if they actually do but it doesn't
sound sufficiently like they do because
of that toxic compassion thing where you
need to say the thing up front that
sounds right even if in the the long run
it results in bad outcomes and as you
inevitably meet the ey of your own side
you inevitably get welcomed by the other
side so I observe I didn't see this
happen with Melissa I'm not saying that
she's like swung right and she's now
going to be employed by the daily wire
or something but
I saw the only support that was
available for this lady that had written
a very well thought out very meaningful
book she wasn't prepared to get out over
a ski she wasn't trying to play a game
and blah blah blah and I I saw this like
you know Purity spiral Witch Hunt
lambasa and then the only side that's
left open is the opposite so you know
there is this sort of polarity where
people just swing straight back across
and go across the other side cuz it's
like hey guess what the you know the
enemy of my enemy is my friend and if my
ex-friend turns out to actually become
my enemy I'm going to go where I'm
welcomed that's totally and by the way
two things you just shared have personal
intersections with me starting with
single parent households my my I my
father died when I was six months old in
you know in Vietnam I I was raised by my
mother for three years uh alone we lived
with my great-grandparents you know I've
explored my personality and and how
those three years without a father
affected me and they did I'd be lying if
I didn't tell you they didn't would it
be better for every child in the world
to grow up in a nurturing loving safe
secure household with a two parents
doesn't doesn't even matter if it's a
mom and dad if you ask me but a a
nurturing household with with love uh
and support yes of course do I think
government can incentivize that or make
that happen no I do I think people have
to this is my argument Chris is we have
to start you know rebuilding communities
and I think that starts with rebuilding
the foundation so that people have a
chance that we have Healthcare and
housing education for all and that way
we have raised the foundation we can
change that but here's the other thing
when I after October 7th what happened
in Israel I got a lot more texts and
calls this is this is before I declared
my candidacy for president I got more
texts and calls from my Republican
colleagues just saying I got you on my
mind I'm so horrified about what
happened in Israel and I know the Jewish
diaspora must be suffering I only got
like two from my Democratic colleagues
and then when I went back for votes
after declaring my campaign for
president my my Democratic colleagues
greeted me warmly but my Republican
colleagues came up to me and looked me
in the eyes and said man your courage I
gotta tell you wow and I got so what you
just said is I'm human you know I'm I'm
I'm Adept enough and mature enough and
have enough life experience to process
some of these uh these circumstances so
I'm not becoming a republican tomorrow
but I see exactly what you just shared
in practice as a human being and when
you drive people out of your tribe of
course they're going to affiliate with
the other side Liz Cheney did that with
us when she was pushed out of the
Republican conference she started
hanging out on our side and you know
what she started voting with us a little
bit more and you know what I did an
advertisement for her last campaign who
would have thought that because I saw
her principle on full display so all I'm
saying is there's a lot of Truth out
there but you got to dig for it and you
got to open your heart and mind and my
goodness I'm learning things every day
some things that I kind of thought were
true other things that have shocked me
because I was on the totally wrong side
of fact and it's been a joyful
experience I just want to maybe end with
that because I got to get running Chris
but if I have a message for anybody look
beyond go broad right not just in your
reading and your uh your Googling and
your your podcasting but find people and
do things that open your mind and make
you see things differently and um and
lead with decency and if we all did that
just a little bit better my goodness the
things we can learn and the places we
can go and I can't wait to help lead us
there Dean Phillips I appreciate you
thank you for the day as I do you Chris
be well and keep the faith if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe